un giro de tuerca o status quo esta es
una de las grandes preguntas de cara al
año nuevo el lunes el ejecutivo francés
debe debatir las posibles restricciones
en un consejo de defensa sanitario el
consejo científico ha propuesto el
regreso del toque de queda para
nochevieja la preocupación va en aumento
ya que francia acaba de superar la
barrera de los 100 mil contagios en 24
horas por primera vez y para algunos
especialistas en la ola podría ser aún
mayor si está en dos rolls en dos
semanas podríamos tener 200.000 casos
diarios si han estado en contacto con
cinco o seis personas un millón de
personas podrían quedar en aislamiento
explicando que ha contacto otra cuestión
que se decidirá en el consejo de defensa
de la salud las modalidades de
aislamiento actualmente una persona que
haya tenido contacto con la variante
omicron debe estar aislada de 7 a 17
días dependiendo de la situación el
gobierno ahora deberá unificar las
normas y reducir su duración medidas
pensadas para evitar un transtorno
social en enero que es lo que teme el
consejo científico
según el journal du dimanche en las
bajas laborales aumentaron en 1 740
entre el 1 de noviembre y el 19 de
diciembre el lunes también se celebrará
un consejo ministerial para aprobar el
proyecto de ley que introduce el pase de
vacunación para sus detractores este
pase sanitario equivale a una vacunación
obligatoria encubierta